I mean literally um I Heard uh Trump say
I want to talk to Vladimir Putin now
he's said nice things about
[Music]
me so as a result of this election you
are you have a ringside seat in the
Trump presidency you're a Russia expert
there's all this question of Trump's
relationship with Putin which Still
Remains you know pretty unclear those
meetings where he has no officials but
the interpreters he seizes the
interpreters notes what on Earth is
going on you can see what's in it for
Putin but what's in it for Trump well I
can tell you a little bit above all of
those incidents because it was a little
bit more oversight than appeared from
the um from the outside but I mean for
Trump it's all about the image that he
wants to conduct and for him you know as
the Americans say um Putin's abadas you
know the like iconic at least he was
until he became you know the Butcher of
Ukraine the AV sunglasses you know the
James Bond look they're all the various
different guys exactly which he doesn't
do thank God anymore wasn't for him to
do it the you know the beginning but
still I he's about to shift somewhat um
and so for Trump it's like everybody
knows who Vladimir Putin is I mean even
if they don't know his in the go that's
that Russia guy isn't it you know when
people are asked on the street and and
Trump wants that kind of respect he
wants that kind of aure and he thinks
that by being with someone or having
them you know talk about him in a
favorable way that rubs off in him and
I'm sorry to say I mean it's just as as
as primitive and as simple as that Trump
is as we've all you know realized um a
complete narcissist and if somebody FS
him FY gets them everywhere I mean
literally um I Heard uh Trump I mean
literally with this distance away uh
after Putin had very deliberately um
been on Russian television and in
interviews prising Trump's handling of
the economy say I want to talk to
Vladimir Putin now he's said nice things
about me so it wasn't about blackmail or
any kind of other information he had on
him we've all got that information on
him it's all out there in public right
now I mean he's got all kinds of
criminal and you know other corruption
and other you know trials against him so
there was no
compromat.ru KGB and you know assessing
his Target is figuring out what people's
bundner buties are what buttons he has
to push and in the case of trump it was
the be nice to me but and you remember
um prime minister AB of Japan you know
really cing uh Trump says Saudi uh king
and the family of the big gold no and uh
just you know kind of putting on you
know big festivals and creating Trump
trophies Putin didn't do any of that but
what he did do was always talk about
Trump in very favorable terms and Trump
was always talking about him with my
friend he had no personal connection
with C he'd never met him before he
exaggerated the natur relationship
because he wanted people to think that
he had the friends of strong men so he
was actually
anti-china but he was pro- Shi for
example presant she because presant she
was um you know also a strong man and
there were several people that you would
you know be a bit surprised he liked the
popee not I think the pope particularly
liked him but it's because he's the pope
and he loved the queen because she's the
queen and it's not these you know
either and Kim J and that was um yeah
it's also old was a very old yeah I
don't think um that' be quite
interesting wouldn't it but anyway so
that was really the dynamic and of
course so Putin as you said there was a
lot in it for Putin because he could
manipulate the situation and I think
that you know we all contributed to um
all of this by getting so obsessed about
the whole you know was he the Moscow not
The Manchurian Candidate because it was
much less to it than met the ey that was
really it and I was seeing this up front
and trying to explain it to people but
everybody wanted to believe that it was
being played by Putin everyone wanted to
believe because Trump was so shocking
the TR proven elected him the course he
hadn't Americans elected him because of
the vagaries of the Electoral College
and in terms
of the these
incidents the interpreters are really
hary skills and their notes some like
journalist notes are in shorthand and we
did De briefs with the interpreters the
instant afterward Trump was never alone
with Putin because Trump doesn't speak
Russian you know so um the danger was
actually with people who spoke English
and would pull him apart we have no idea
about all kinds of other conversations
but we have a pretty good idea about
what happened in the conversations
between Trump and Putin so I we could
happily talk for hours we have a limited
time and I want to get on to where we
are now um Russia Ukraine was there a
way of handling Putin that would have
made any difference might he not have
invaded look I think a lot of his
decision making about um invading uh was
really influenced by coid I'm we all
been affected by coid um and Vladimir
Putin sadly in ways that yeah I think
most of us you know not acting out
invasions of other countries as a result
although I mean plenty of people felt
angry about stuff during the the co
period but he was in complete isolation
in that time I mean you remember the
regret B long table uh and you know
meeting with people way over the I mean
doesn't really give them a lot of
opportunity to give him briefings he
reduced down uh those a pool of people
who were um providing him advice uh one
of the presidential um Administration
units that used to kind of bundle
information for him they kind of
imploded exploded and you know got uh
disbanded and so he was just kind of
meeting with close confidence that he
trusted who obviously you know kind of
we've seen this happen so many of the
times before haven't we you just get bad
advice from the people you let close to
you and other people had to quarantine
for two weeks you know before they would
go allow to see him in person so most of
the people who could have told him
really bad idea to do this didn't get
access to him and others just didn't
were too frightened to say anything
because he seems to have been stewing in
his own juices for the whole period of
Co basically thinking about his legacy
and you know he's obviously trying to
you be president you know it's all time
in Memorial but thinking about the way
that he was going to be like one of the
great Zars he kind of moved into this
basically position of thinking himself
as a character in history and his own
history and his own Narrative of Russian
history and wanting to take back Russian
LS and there was nobody really to tell
him to stop and I don't think that
that's where he was headed at the very
beginning of his uh presidency but I
think that's you know where he ended up
and Co honestly did play a big role in
that in terms of not not being any check
it was we now know I think a lot more
and you know you can read about all of
the papers that you know the people like
Victor medb Chuck of of an oligarch from
Russia from Ukraine rather who was very
close to him Putin's The Godfather of
his daughter who's telling him it'll be
really easy he we've heard that before
Iraq you might remember in 2003 you'll
be met with flowers you know this was
exactly what he was being told you know
so basically Putin is lulled into sort
of thinking that he's going to literally
just walk into Ukraine or few tanks and
few convoys and Ukraine is just going to
crumble annexing Ukraine is going to be
joining Russia in the same way that
belus you know had done before yeah yeah
so now we have the Limitless friendship
between shinin and and and Putin we have
a United States with a serious loss of
influence after Trump now seen as an
unreliable Ally in many parts of the
world so the postwar order if you like
much discussed it looks extremely
fragile we're in big shifts of of
economic power big shifts of of of the
understanding of how you managing uh
Global Affairs you know if you're
looking at the next 10 years what do you
see I mean we're not going to see the
same kind of hierarchical World Order uh
that we've had in the past and I don't
think it's going to be one that you know
this time around after another big you
know war in Europe that's going to be
shaped by the United States alone I mean
even in conjunction with Europeans cuz
you know you're an expert on China you
know that obviously China you know has
its own thoughts about this and there's
all kinds of alternative orders already
emerging that China is part of bricks
you know the um the Shanghai cooperation
organization all kinds of uh other ways
of managing pacy and relationships but I
think what we're also seeing as a result
of uh war in Ukraine is a kind of
rebellion of everyone against United
States I mean I'm sure there are some of
you here who think while the United
States is all to blame for this law
because of NATO enlargement remember
countries like Poland and the Czech
Republic and Hungary and Baltic states
wanted to join NATO and the fact that
Finland and Sweden now want to join she
di be telling everybody something the
fins and the swedes were neutral own the
Swedish case for hundreds of years and
the the fins right up until the invasion
was saying we'd never join NATO but then
when they see what Russia was doing you
know the fins in particular remember
that they were part of the Russian
Empire and that you know they had
basically I think a fifth of their
territory taken in the winter war in
1939 all up um area of corellia north of
St Petersburg and we think well hang on
if he's got this in his fever
imagination of you know history of um
wanting to take back Ukraine what he
wants to take back the duy of Finland or
the polls thinking the grand duy of
Warsaw those were also a part of the
Russian Empire and if he's saying you
know history only began in 1783 when
Russia took Crimea what about the rest
of us here are we going back to this age
of empir exactly and they're saying well
hang on a second so you know we need to
be doing something this is a fight for
the future of Europe with you know
basically Vladimir Putin heading what's
still the last great land Empire um in
the European space plus you know the
fact that many people think the United
States did this just goes to show that
there's a real backlash against United
States influence and power and it's
highly unlikely that the United States
will get in support um to basically
rethink you know um institutions I think
we are still seeing however a great deal
of interest in the United Nations not in
the United Nations security Council but
you you've seen all of the and all of
you've been watching these resolutions
in the UN General Assembly there still
is a great deal of interest in upholding
international law sovereignty and
territorial Integrity United States
hasn't been perfect on that score of
course but there is a lot of of interest
in other countries of trying to
reestablish as a in the course of war in
Ukraine those basic facts but there's
not an interest in creating a new
hierarchical world order and and there's
not a l of interest in a clash between
the United States in China I think
that's partly why we've seen Biden
trying to patch things up a little bit
and try to take down the temperature
over the last couple of weeks because
the realization that rest of the world
is not ready for another clash of the
superpower Titans to continue watching
this video click the link in the top
left or in the description below or
visit I a.tv for more debates and talks
from the world's leading thinkers on
today's biggest
ideas